the toy companies designers prepare a
sketch of the figurine showing not just
the physical characteristics such as
size colors and textures but also the
body pose and facial expression once the
sketch is finalized modelers use
specialized software to transform it
into a drawing for a three-dimensional
model then a 3d printer produces a model
in plastic the company also employs
modelers who work the traditional way
with Wax
the modeler makes the wax or plastic
model accordingly this Dino is divided
into four parts head body jaw and tongue
for each one workers now make a silicon
mold to cast several copies in hard
plastic that unlike the model material
can withstand repeated handling workers
fill a metal box they assemble around
the part with silicone about 12 hours
later when the silicone has cured they
cut it open and extract the model then
they use the vacated cavity to cast
several hard plastic copies of the part
one copy however goes to the companies
tool makers who use it to fabricate the
production mold they bury the copy and
putty but just up to the mid point next
they set the half-buried copy in a metal
form and fill to the top with plaster
once the plaster hardens they cure it in
an oven for about an hour then they
extract the putty to copy what's left in
the plaster is a cavity in the shape of
half the copy they now fill that cavity
with molten zinc alloy dwith copper
aluminum and magnesium once the metal
cools and solidifies they break the
plaster and voila one half of the
two-part metal production mold they
repeat the entire process to make the
other half
workers mount the two-part mold in an
injection molding machine the machine
shoots hot molten plastic into the mold
cavity immediately cools the plastic
enough to solidify it then ejects the
figurine or figurine part the plastic is
solid but still soft so they harden it
further in cold water the figurines then
go to the art department where artists
can paint them using both traditional
and air brushes once the paint dries
it's assembly time a worker glues the
Dinos tongue into the hinged jaw snaps
the jaw into the head then glues the
head to the body this ferocious beast is
ready to hit the playground